- [Instructor] Growing
up in Southern Idaho,
one of my favorite places
to visit was Swan Falls,
a gorgeous canyon formed
by the snake river.
All throughout my childhood,
I remember scrambling
over the boulders down in this canyon
and playing in the cool water
at the edge of the river.
Over thousands and thousands of years,
water slowly eroded
away rock and sediment.
Water made this canyon and
water forms many landscapes,
including valleys, ravines,
cliffs, coastlines,
all of these were largely
shaped and affected by water.
And given that water
covers most of the earth,
or over 70% of it,
it's no surprise that water
also shapes the earth.
Water is a powerful force.
It can literally wash away soil
and carve away rock bit by bit,
which scientists describe
through two separate processes.
When water breaks rocks
apart, it's called weathering.
And when water carries away
surface soil, sediments,
and that broken down
rock it's called erosion.
Erosion by water starts with rain.
During a rain storm the impact
of raindrops is actually powerful enough
to dislodge soil particles
and damage soil structure.
This is called mechanical weathering.
As rainwater starts to accumulate,
it can erode a landscape by moving soil
and rock particles, called sediment,
away from their original location.
And as water flows down the
slope of hills and mountains,
it transports sediment along with it.
Eventually water gathers
into small streams
and then rivers, carrying
more and more sediment.
In fact, through erosion,
water carries away billions
of tons of sediment to
the oceans every year.
Plant roots and vegetation
can hold soil in place
and prevent or slow soil erosion.
But if soil has nothing to hold it down,
water can erode away soil very quickly.
As the volume of water increases,
so does its power of erosion.
In turn, a large river can erode more soil
and rock quicker than a small river can.
The speed of the water flow
also affects its erosional power.
Simply put, faster moving
water can carry more sediment.
This relationship is one
reason why fast moving water
causes more erosion than the same volume
of slow moving water.
A great example of water
erosion in relation to speed
is that of meandering
rivers and Oxbow lakes.
You know, the weird horseshoe
looking lake in this image.
Let's take a look at how
these Oxbow lakes form.
The current of the water is fastest
on the outside of the bend.
In turn, these are the
areas where water tends
to erode away the river bank.
Conversely, the current
of the water is slowest
on the inside of a bend.
Here, the water slows
down so much that some
of the sediment that is
being carried is dropped,
or deposited.
This is called sedimentation.
Over time, through erosion and deposition,
an Oxbow lake will form,
which is eventually
cut off from the river.
Chemical weathering as another way
that water can break rocks,
such as when acids in water
dissolve certain types
of rocks and minerals.
Over time, flowing water
can dissolve the minerals
and rocks on or under the surface.
This chemical weathering
can cause sinkholes,
caves, and cliffs to form.
Certain rocks like limestone
are especially vulnerable to erosion.
In particular, limestone easily erodes due
to carbonic acid and rainwater,
which forms when carbon dioxide, or CO2,
from the atmosphere dissolves in water.
In turn limestone erosion can produce
intricate cave systems.
Along beaches and the ocean front,
coastal erosion breaks
up and wears away rock.
As waves sweep in over and over,
they cause rock to weather
away and break off.
Going back to the Snake
River and Swan Falls,
I can see examples of weathering
and erosion all around me.
I look to the cliffs which
have been slowly carved away
by the Snake River over time
to reveal this amazing valley,
which was formed by
weathering and water erosion.
Water erosion is incredibly powerful
and although it can be
destructive by removing soil
and rock over thousands
and thousands of years,
water erosion is also responsible
for creating the beautiful
and spectacular landscapes
that we enjoy today.